mais vous avez énuméré toute une série toute une série
dernières étapes dernières étapes
l'administration des États-Unis, qui
en général, il brille sur une chose à propos de l'intention
l'administration Trump à tout faire pour ne pas
être lié par aucun
international multilatéral
obligations
de la même série, bien sûr, le phénomène x
sanctions territoriales lorsque
les états-unis décident que la chine
représente une menace car
se vend aussi beaucoup aux états-unis
peu d'achats auxquels ils imposent des restrictions
importer de la République populaire de Chine
quand les états-unis décident que l'iran
bien qu'il fasse tout ce qui concerne
convenu d'un commun accord
plan d'action global sur le nucléaire
affaires quand même
se comporte mal de l'avis du connecté
déclare, encore une fois, tout le reste comme non
envisager d'imposer des sanctions contre l'Iran
quand les États-Unis pensent que
le président nicolas maduro venezuela aussi
mérite la punition qu'ils annoncent
sanctions à son encontre
puis déclarer à tous les autres pays
monde n'ose pas commercer avec ces pays
que veulent les États-Unis
isoler veux isoler conversation avec
nos collègues américains en Iran
en tout cas, il repose sur le même
la plupart des problèmes ont été résolus par le
indique que le plan global conjoint
actions pour gérer la situation
environ
L'atome iranien était une mauvaise affaire
a dit le président Trump et quoi
l'administration obama a fait une erreur
colossal une si mauvaise affaire
conclure et maintenant s'il vous plaît quelques années
retour les états-unis sont sortis de ça
plan global conjoint
actions, mais a en même temps déclaré que
personne ne peut arrêter
les états-unis quand ils veulent
punir l'iran
pour le fait que l'Iran aurait violé
alors d'où viennent les sons des états-unis
paradoxal et assez maladroit
c'est en fait si les USA ont dit que je ne l'avais pas fait
Je remplirai mes obligations et celles-ci
obligations n'étaient pas de
imposer des sanctions contre l'iran supprimer tous
sanctions existantes et permettre à l'Islam
République d'Iran à participer pleinement
commerce international et économie
Échanges